Senegal is doing what most countries
count testing everyone symptoms are not
entering a health center for the novel
coronavirus it has no shortage of
testing kit thanks to this lab at the
MCG beste researchers are developing a
$1 quick diagnostic kit originally made
to test for dengue fever patients drop
blood or saliva onto the devices and
wait for blood line to appear like a
pregnancy tests explains researcher a
Medusa as there is no need for a highly
equipped lab it's a simple test that can
be done anywhere
the idea is to rapidly produce two to
four million kids not just for us but
for African countries so that we can
detect it and isolate patients quickly
the sick are administered a cheap
anti-malarial drug called chloroquine
commonly found in sub-saharan Africa
where malaria is endemic while the World
Health Organization cautions the use of
it the car born scientists DJ Howells
says it's an affordable treatment for
poor African countries dealing with the
outbreak hydroxychloroquine is clearing
the virus from as a respiratory system
probably making that people are no more
contagious and no more sick
with only 50 ventilator machines for 16
million people Senegalese engineer are
using a 3d printing machine to produce
more while imported ventilators cost
$16,000 this one is just 60 dollars
Senegal is counting the cost and it's
paying off more than a month into the
outbreak the small West African nation
suffered only two deaths with most
patients treated healed Senegal has the
largest rate of recovery in patients
infected with the corona virus in Africa
the third in the world ahead of
countries like the United States and
France and while it has a tiny health
budget compared to those countries it
has a wealth of experience in dealing
with infectious diseases and outbreaks
over 3,000 children died of pneumonia
last year in Senegal thousands more from
malaria coronavirus is one of many
deadly infections the country is dealing
with lessons learnt from the AIDS
epidemic the recent Ebola outbreak were
key in Senegal strategy in dealing with
the pandemic I'm optimistic because some
measures are taken already closing the
airport
no imported case coming in the country
limitation of movement confinement of
people from 8 p.m. to 6 a.m. I think
those things can help these measures
were taken when there were less than a
hundred cases scientific modeling
predicted tens of thousands of
infections and hundreds of death but
this has not happened early detection an
african-led research means Senegal is so
far beating the odds
Nicholas Hawk al Jazeera Dakar